one of the last surviving battle Briton
Spitfire pilots Ken Wilkinson has died
at the age of 99
he was among those famously called the
few by Winston Churchill born in Cumbria
Ken Wilkinson was selected for the Royal
Air Force at the outbreak of the war and
was chosen to fly a Spitfire in recent
years he shared his experiences of the
war saying I was one of the lucky ones
he spoke to us in 2015 on the 75th
anniversary of the Battle of Britain on
1st of September 39 I wrote myself off I
thought you've got no chance lasting
through whatever it's going to be
because it was quite obvious that the
way the Germans were moving they were
going to make a hell of a war out of it
and so I was ready for war the
unfortunate smiled on me and not under
some of the others former Royal Air
Force officer John Nichol one of our
regular contributors of course knew Ken
wilkinson joins us now
hello to John thanks for joining us
commiserations I know that you you knew
Ken how would you describe him to our
viewers oh he was an absolute gentleman
ki I did those interviews for Sky 2
years ago as part of the 75th
anniversary celebrations and known Ken
for about 10 15 years he knew a load of
people and every I'd been tweeting about
it today and everybody who replies who
say who said it met him always talked
about what a gentleman he was how humble
he was and and most importantly how
whenever they met him in whatever
situation he had a glass of red wine in
his hand and that's true if you look at
some of the pictures kicking around he's
with Prince Charles with a glass of red
wine and a pound
he's with Prince William Prince Harry
and every time he's smiling he's got a
massive grin on his face he loved his
life and he was proud of what he did but
he was very humble and he rarely spoke
about it and he certainly never regarded
himself as a hero he described himself
as one of the lucky ones he's certainly
been
been described by Churchill as one of
the few he must have had some stories to
tell he did you know that he arrived on
his squadron in October so towards 13 or
the last month of the Battle of Britain
in 1940 but he certainly saw a bit of
action and and he talked about how he
could not allow they called them the
untidy creatures coming from the other
side of the channel to attack his
country and that was what they all
thought about and the sacrifice and the
numbers are fairly staggering so there
were about 3,000 men flew during the
Battle of Britain and of those 3544
killed during the battle and then
another just over 800 in the course of
the second world war so of the 3,000 who
served in the Battle of Britain 1,400
lost their lives in the Second World War
so Ken was lucky and they all thought
they were lucky he never said it was
because of my skill it was because of my
professional professionalism because of
my expertise he said it was because I
was lucky I was just one of the ones who
got away with it about airplanes but I'm
gonna say that that's a Spitfire that
he's photographed with there he flew
this before I didn't do yeah he did he
was on six one seven squadron sorry six
one six squadron and 19 squadron and
then he went off to be during the Battle
of Britain and then he went off to be to
be an instructor and you know the
Spitfire was at the the heart of the
Battle of Britain and Ken was in that
aircraft and about 20,000 Spitfires
produced fraud during the war a huge
number from those early marked ones at
the beginning of the war and the Battle
of Britain all the way through to the
end of the war and many people would say
that you know there clearly there were
many other aircraft but for some reason
the Spitfire holds its place in the
nation's heart there are still a couple
flying with the RAF Battle of Britain
Memorial Flight along with one of the
Hurricanes again bravely fought in the
Battle of Britain but for summary when
ever I'm out and about at an airshow or
at an event when you hear that Spitfire
engine roar
people stop and stare they literally
stop what they're doing and looked
skyward and when you hear one it's
amazing can you imagine being over
London in 1940 and seeing a hundred two
hundred of these aircrafts take to the
skies to fight maybe three four five
hundred German bombers approaching
that's what ken did that's what his
friends did and he kind of didn't talk
that much about them - then they
regarded it as just a job and if they
didn't do it who would